وفقًا لسجلات guinness العالمية ، فإن
أسرع أفعوانية على هذا الكوكب
تصل سرعتها إلى 149 ميلًا في
الساعة ، وتمتد أطول أفعوانية لأكثر من
ميل ونصف ،
وتقلبك تلك التي بها معظم الانقلابات
رأسًا على عقب 14
مرة وأقدم أفعوانية لا تزال
تعمل  تم بناؤه في عام 1912.
لماذا نرفع كل هذا
الآن ،
يا كارل في خضم هذا الوباء العالمي ،
لقد تحدثنا كثيرًا عن مدى
صعوبة الحياة بالنسبة للكثيرين منا الذين
أعلم أننا نتطلع جميعًا إلى
العودة
إلى طبيعتها بعد عام من الصعود والهبوط ، ومن
أجل
العودة إلى المرح
اليوم ، سأخبرك عن
قطار أفعواني جديد قيد الإنشاء
يمكن أن يصنع التاريخ ، يطلق عليه
رحلة الصقر
، ستكون الرحلة هي الرحلة الرئيسية  جاذبية
ستة أعلام كاديا التي من المقرر افتتاحها في
المملكة العربية السعودية خارج العاصمة
الرياض في عام 2023
، تم تعيينها لتحطيم جميع الأرقام القياسية الحالية
لارتفاع سرعة الأفعوانية
وطول المسار
الذي ستسافر فيه السفينة عبر 2.5 ميل  مسار
رائع مع استخدام تسريع المحرك المغناطيسي ،
سيختبر الدراجون
الإحساس بالغوص فوق
جرف عمودي
في واد بعمق 525 قدمًا محققين
سرعات غير مسبوقة تصل إلى 155 ميلاً
في الساعة
وفقًا لبيانهم الصحفي الذي
ستستغرقه رحلة الصقر  ما يصل إلى 20
راكبًا
في رحلة طويلة مدتها ثلاث دقائق توفر
مناظر بانورامية على قمة ما سيكون
أطول هيكل كوستر قائم بذاته في العالم ،
يتم بناء هذه السفينة الدوارة من
قبل الشركة الحميمة والتي
تصادف أن يكونوا
منشئوا أطول كوستر حاليًا في
العالم  مصنوعة من الفولاذ ، الملك
داكار الذي يمكن العثور عليه في ستة أعلام
مغامرة رائعة في نيو جيرسي
الآن إذا كنت
مثلي وفكرت في غرق مئات الأقدام
تجعل معدتك تنقلب
جيدًا ، فهناك دائمًا النهر البطيء